ambiguity paradox confusion are also
some of my favorite subjects the two
lines that we often see in the Far East
it's they're supposed to represent
confusion and paradox and they guard the
gate to heaven so if you want to get to
heaven quote you have to be comfortable
with confusion and with paradox and one
example of being comfortable with
paradox as we often hear that we should
accept life the way it is and but of
course there are many things that we
don't accept so we can have the paradox
of accepting that we can't accept I mean
we can't accept violence against women
or children or even against other men
but we can accept that we can't accept
that so the paradox in this case
extremely extremely important so it's
not a whitewash to say hey I accept
everything that's nonsense to begin with
but where do you parts of where do you
say that you accept something something
or not and being comfortable with the
paradox of accepting but also accepting
that we do not accept certain things
that's that's how paradox plants plays
itself out and confusion is that we live
in an extremely complex world and it's
not a straight and narrow most things
have an upside and a downside and to
weigh them out is it's very difficult
you know we we would love to have a very
simple answer a black-and-white answer
is it good for me as a bad for me but
that's very rarely the case we evolved
to want to have simple answers because
the brain then doesn't have to work
overtime to analyze any situation and
the more complex the situation and the
more confusing the more the brain has to
work that's why we don't like confusion
we want to have simple straightforward
black-and-white answers but that's
probably not gonna happen for anything I
don't like the word right and wrong
because for different people right and
wrong looks very different I think that
it can be coached in a little bit of a
different way so I like to look at
things that work or they don't work I
believe that human beings fundamentally
want life to flourish we love and when
we see life flourish be it a new flower
or a tree sprouting in the springtime or
any beautiful new thing that we
experience a new baby it's it's just we
love it and we have a really positive
feeling towards when life flourishes so
right and wrong gets it very much into a
mental status and we compared to a whole
list of what we think is good for life
and what we think is bad for life but
underlying I think it's much more
interesting to pay attention to whether
something works to have life flourish or
not so if you step on an ant obviously
that doesn't help very much for life to
flourish is it right or wrong to kill a
mosquito I don't know you know I mean in
my book it's it works for me so the
mosquito doesn't give me malaria so it
helps my life to flourish but obviously
it doesn't help the mosquitos life to
flourish so I believe it's much more
valuable to recognize it in terms of
working and not working rather than
right and wrong